what's going on guys today we finally
got the trailer for part two of attack
on time the final season and while it
was only 30 seconds long i'm gonna break
down any small details you might have
missed
along with the trailer part two is also
now confirmed to start on the 9th of
january 2022 and we also got a new
comment from isayama which i'll talk
about at the end of the video
when the season starts again next year i
will be doing weekly episode breakdowns
on the channel like i did for the first
half so if you haven't already then be
sure to hit that sub button and uh yeah
let's just get into the trailer
okay so the whole thing kicks off with
aaron standing in front of the
coordinate which is the thing that
connects all aldeans and gives them the
potential to become titans although it's
not explained why he's standing here we
know from yamir's memories that people
can see these paths whenever they enter
the past dimension implying that that's
exactly where aaron is
the scene moves over to aaron and reiner
confronting each other in shiganshina as
at the end of part one the armored titan
was seen approaching war maria in
airship alongside the other malian
forces during their fight in the trailer
we see that reiner stabs him with a
warhammer titan crystal confirming that
aaron used the warhammer titan's power
earlier in the battle back in season 4
aaron did use the warhammer titans power
once when he was escaping jail but to be
fair that moment happened completely off
screen so this fight in chicago is going
to be the first time we probably see him
utilize it in the anime on top of this
we see gabby and falca running through
the city alongside colt who of course is
falco's older brother these three were
separated ever since the two warrior
candidates decided to you know take a
one-way trip to paradise island so the
fact that all together means that
somehow falco was freed from his prison
cell which is the last place we saw him
hanji and captain levi then make a brief
appearance and the former has a shocked
expression on their face here because
levi pretty much looks like a corpse
towards the end of the last season the
captain was blown up after zeke
detonated the thunderspear that was
inside him but although he looks
terrible the trailer doesn't actually
confirm anything about whether he's dead
or alive
things then switch back over to
shiganshina as malian troops begin
parachuting into the district but this
is contrasted by the airships all being
on fire and elena here having the time
of her life i won't go into spoilers
about why the airships are like this but
it goes without saying that obviously
this is not something the marlins would
want to happen
this scene is followed by a quick moment
of gabby using the kart titan's mouth is
like her own personal taxi and i gotta
say the service looks a lot more
comfortable than the one zeke had to
deal with in season three
mikasa then appears with her thinking
face on as she's holding the scarf that
erin gave her when they were younger and
as you can tell from the background
she's still locked up at this time
after this the rest of the trailer is
mostly just very fast reaction shots
with my favorite being zeke desperately
calling out to someone as he stretches
out his hand because on his body his
time shifter marks are clearly visible
that confirms that at some point between
this screenshot and his last appearance
in the series which is when he was being
shoved into a titan stomach zeke
transformed into the beast titan at
least one more time
as i said the remainder of the trailer
is just people reacting to things some
more dramatically than others and the
final moment is aaron inside the attack
titan still fighting against reiner we
actually saw a very similar moment from
the first trailer for the final season
that came out ages ago so yeah this is
just a variation of that
anyway like i said in the intro there
was also a message from isayama
regarding part 2 which should be on
screen and the translation says i'm
really looking forward to the start of
the second half of the final season even
in the original the manga it was very
difficult drawing and i am very sorry
that mapper will have a hard time again
for many teams that the assistants had a
hard time with the difficult scenes are
the ones i'm looking forward to the most
and i hope that people who see it for
the first time in the anime will also
enjoy it
so from the way that sounds it's
basically like isaiah's apology that is
to map up for you know the spectacles
they've had to animate for the second
half of the season but hopefully even
though the scenes are super difficult
hopefully he can still do some justice
to the manga regardless thank you for
watching this breakdown of the very
short trailer for part two of the final
season and i hope it gave you a little
bit of insight or made you realize
something that you didn't see when
watching it for the first time like i
said be sure to sub if you want to see
weekly episode breakdowns when the
season starts back again and until the
next one peace out